Russian State tv threatens nuclear
strike on U.S oh boy well Tucker Carlson
said they're not going to bring back
mandates or lockdowns that he did that
the next way that they gain control over
the U.S they're going to start a hot war
with Russia I think it's fair Tucker
does mention this we're at war with
Russia and anybody saying otherwise is
lying U.S Personnel is on the are on the
ground volunteers they're using U.S
equipment they're trained by NATO
they're trained by the US they're
provided intelligence by the U.S
missiles by the U.S the UK's sending
depleted uranium tank Busters yeah it is
NATO versus Russia it's a proxy war
well now we have this story this could
be
Newsweek and uh Western media trying to
ramp up fear that there is a reason to
go to war with Russia you I'll give you
the long the long story short of it you
have uh this guy it's not it's not it's
korchenko right yes editor of the
newspaper National Defense he basically
said
Russia is being worn and threatened that
if we misbehave or if you know Ben
Hodge's opinion we exceed what he
considers to be the necessary
permissible lines those all for the use
of all types of Russian weapons he
threatens us with more than just strikes
on the Crimean Bridge he responds by
basically saying if you engage in war
with us we will not go to war with the
US in Europe we will go to war with the
US on U.S territory
he doesn't respond to your tax on
Russian military or civilian facilities
the first strike will be a preventative
limited strike against Targets on the
territory of the United States of
America
I think it's BS
uh they point out in Newsweek and a
couple other outlets the most effective
way to use nuclear weapons by the
Russians is to claim they have them and
that's it but it makes no sense to
Target U.S civilian uh territorial
targets because all that would do is
make their position in in Eastern Europe
worse
I agree Russia has no reason to do this
this is some random guy that goes on
Russian State tv maybe he's looking for
a better paying job and he's trying to
come out and say but the fact the matter
is Russia controls 87 000 square
kilometers of Ukrainian territory the
you know the ratio of Russian troops
Ukrainian troops lost is insane
Ukraine's lost 400 000 Plus Men Russia
maybe 150 000 they have no reason to do
something as Extreme as this and that
really wouldn't be in Putin's you know
line of governance either let's uh let's
make all of the corporate media Outlets
uh happy and give them an article to
write about yeah what's the likelihood
you think that the U.S would engage in a
false flag to justify expansive uh
expanding the war in Ukraine
I think they already did I mean that was
2014 when the maidon massacre took place
the Western press all said it was a
bunch of uh you know Ukrainian
government Yanukovych aligned
individuals that rained down with sniper
fire on the protesters and made on
Square
12 years later we learned that it was
actually Georgian Legion snipers that
were out there nine years nine years
nine years later 2014. nine years later
it was Georgian snipers that were out
there at the behest of the Ukrainian Now
new Ukrainian government you know we
know that for for sure I've not heard
that yeah Canadian researcher look him
up he did the study it was George and
snipers that did it also in Oliver
Stone's documentary he touched on that
subject but
the snipers were firing from the the
buildings around Madeon square that were
controlled by the A's of aligned
individuals within the grab for power
so here's all I can say as to that claim
Western media Outlets say that it's
propaganda issued by Russia and Russia
now let's say it's confirmed So This Is
War it's War who you saying people will
die yeah but just like the idea that uh
I will say it's it's not above any
warring Nation to engage in a false flag
especially as it pertains to
overthrowing a government the U.S is
going to claim and Western powers are
going to claim this is what the the
Russian online government was doing and
Russia is going to claim it was Western
forces trying to overthrow the
government and stall their their their
their their puppet and then also I mean
look at this you have the uh you know I
won't give my full opinion on YouTube
but you have the Nord train pipeline
incident and you add everyone in the
west who's saying that was Russia it was
definitely Russia and I think everyone
knows who it really was you can look at
the uh the Kremlin drone attack they
were saying that was a false flag by
Russia then we turn to find out that the
Ukrainian government put a postage stamp
out celebrating a Ukrainian Soldier
flying the drone over the Kremlin and
bombing it I mean the list goes on I'm
sure Russia maybe they yeah this is
happen but absolutely and that's clear
we have this from The Washington Post
U.S had intelligence of detailed
Ukrainian plan to attack Nordstrom
pipeline the CIA learned last June via a
European spy agency that a six-person
team of Ukrainian Special Operations
forces intended to sabotage the Russian
to Germany natural gas project they
claimed over and over and over again
that Russia did it they even speculated
that Russia could have Dropped a Bomb
through the pipeline so it got to that
point it blew up which makes literally
no sense Russia Vladimir Putin banglak I
have the perfect way to defeat my
enemies I'll blow up my own oil pipeline
what it didn't make any sense and yet
this was the all of the western media
was like that's the only explanation
Russia must have done it and then slowly
it sort of came out that oh actually
that's this thing that seems improbable
is actually probably not true yeah it
was a it you know it was what it was
whoever did it I mean that's the CIA
Washington Post saying it was Ukraine
who did it Seymour Hersh has other ideas
you know Biden Administration but at its
core what happened with that I mean it
was an escalation of War it prevented
Germany from being able to negotiate
with the Russians by turning the Taps
back on for the Nordstrom Pipeline and
it made a real big issue for Europe they
had to buy Russian liquefied natural gas
they bought 40 percent more liquefied
natural gas from Russia in the EU over
the past year so I mean it just caused
prices to go up you have the German
economy you have the French economy of
the Italian economy that are all in
shambles right now Europe is in an
inflationary crisis they're about to be
in a recession Germany's already in a
recession I mean it's quite clear what's
happening what do you think is the ideal
circumstance right now related to the
war in in Ukraine like how a peace deal
resolution yeah how like what what is it
well I mean I think I think if you
listen to Putin which no one in the
western press and Western governments
they try not to you know I think he's
quite clear about the fact that uh this
87 000 square kilometers of territory
they've already taken is formerly now
part of the Russian Federation and it
should be respected as such the former
French president has come out last week
and said that you know there should be
formal referendums in these regions to
actually decide whether or not they want
to join Russia we've already seen these
elections though and they they weren't
internationally regulated but these
people said they wanted to join the
Russian Federation and I think Russia is
not going to stop and try for a peace
deal again until they get nikolaev in
Odessa which will landlock Ukraine and
also get the heart of region in the
Northeast I think once they get that
maybe they'll try to push for peace
proposals again but until then I mean
it's gonna be it's gonna be the same old
same old people unfortunately are going
to die because no one in the west is
serious about pushing for peace
what are the major differences between
Soviet Russia
um well
the main differences I think
I don't know I think the Soviet Union
was pretty base but I think that the
Russian economy today if you look at the
economy if you talk about that uh what
what is the basis of the Russian economy
well you know Soviet Union at its start
the country was at its knees you had
basically a feudal society and the
Soviet Union took it from took it from
its knees to a war superpower won the
second world war at the cost of 27
million people but it also centralized
the important sectors of government and
we're seeing that in Russia today
instead of in the United States where we
have all these these rapacious you know
private companies that are hoarding our
our resources hoarding our oil hoarding
our gas hoarding our coal whatever and
Russia they have it under a public
structure you know it's under the
government and they can actually you
know utilize these systems to benefit
the people and negotiate with other
countries like brics partners and terms
that are going to be beneficial to the
Russian economy and the central bank and
that's what's happening with bricks you
know they're they're expanding very fast
this is this is this is this this
matters a lot pull up check take a look
at this from the BBC
Russian military control
look at this
they have all going all the way down to
Kirsten nearly nearly to Odessa all of
Crimea and everything is under Russian
military control
we keep getting told or we've been told
over and over again that the ukrainians
are pushing back but it really feels
like what they're doing is for every 10
10 conflicts that arise let's say 10
battles Ukraine wins one that gets
reported in the press and so everything
we hear is like they're they're
counteroffensive is working they're
gaining ground
this is crazy and not anybody who's been
keeping track of this I mean look it's
Russia's basically won they've taken the
Don best they've taken the land bridge
to Crimea they've got it and it's not
over yet and not just that but the
cities that Ukraine is taking uh if you
look at the pre-war populations for
these cities it's like it's like 50
homes 400 people maybe a few Farms it's
nothing uh in this big counter offensive
that we put all this money to Ukraine
hasn't even reached the first line of
Russian defense fortifications they have
three lines of defense fortifications
that they've been building up since last
November behind those three lines they
have tens of thousands of reservists and
then back in Russia they have even more
reservist soldiers than Russian soldiers
in the whole of Ukraine right now so
it's only going to go in one way it's
going to go I guess two ways maybe
however Russia wants this to end or
mutually assured destruction whatever
whatever happened with the Bak moot
situation because I know that just was
in the news for the Ukraine war for a
while and now pragosian which I'm also
curious to your thoughts about how
that's all played out what's the deal
with Bach moot because I feel like we've
almost seen a stalemate there's been no
progress either way
at least someone from as a casual
Observer of what's been happening in the
war so yeah I'm curious your thoughts uh
Wagner under the leadership of pregosian
uh so when he was still alive you know
months ago they they fully liberated the
city they took it 100 so none of it
remains in Ukrainian control there's
still some firefighting on like the
flanks the outside regions of bakmut or
artimovsk and uh basically what's going
to happen over the next several months
is the Russians are about to start an
offensive of their own because they
defeated the counter-offensive from
Ukraine they're going to focus on the
flanks of Bach moot they're going to
focus on maybe her son and they're
definitely going to focus on taking back
the whole strip of land in the Northeast
the hark of region they're going to
probably take all of that back
and then we'll have some down period and
then next spring is when you're gonna
have the large blowout of the Russian
soldiers pushing in the South all the
way through her son to Odessa they're
going to completely landlock it and take
all of that okay it's kind of crazy to
see you know because I've not been
actively tracking the maps of control
but
they kept saying that Ukraine's winning
Russia's losing they're on the verge of
defeat they kept saying that Russia is
suffering massive casualties and like
let's operate the assumption that the
reporting about massive Russian
casualties was correct and Ukraine was
winning
how does Russia now have total military
military control of the land bridge to
Crimea and then some
and it's not like this is you know under
contest in marupal Rush has already gone
in they've built new schools new grocery
stores new hospitals they've built free
apartments for the people there they're
happy you know and and the the numbers
are lies as I'm sure you know we can all
assume they lie about everything in the
mainstream press I mean Ukraine's a lot
it's it's like a generation of men 400
000 men Russia's got four times the
population of Ukraine how could anyone
ever expect that Ukraine was going to
win I saw a meme that
could be propaganda who knows and it was
a a 4chan green text where it was a
Ukrainian dude he was like you know one
year ago I'm I'm engaged about to get
married I'm working at my job making an
okay wage everything's fine
he's like today log on to social media
and see my my fiance dancing in a
dress in Germany having a party at a
rave and I just got my draft papers I'm
gonna be sent to the front lines where
I'll probably die why is my life like
this
yeah the people people there I mean
I gotta be honest the people I knew
flood
the people that I knew from Ukraine
aren't there anymore and they're posting
pictures on the beach and other places
and I'm just like what is
Russia is moving in they're taking and
I'm just seeing the media lie about
what's going on every step of the way
how do we end this and just say enough
because at this point I don't see an
argument based on this map for Russia
gives up territory at one in the
military conflict you lost perhaps a
piece still could have happened a long
time ago before Boris Johnson destroyed
it and then you could have actually
preserved some of this land under
Ukrainian control or prevented the death
of people and seated it in the first
place I don't see how this ends well for
the rest of Ukraine or for NATO
I do honestly think that if if U.S
interests in NATO
refused to let go of this it's going to
escalate into a more direct conflict
I think it depends on who gets elected
Trump said
he sounds insane when he says I'm gonna
end the war in 24 hours right I believe
it but yeah of course we believe it
because if you withhold funding for
Ukraine their government collapses in
hours their government employees their
soldiers their pensions their
firefighters their police the corrupt
people you know stripping people off the
streets to go on the front they're all
funded by the U.S taxpayer so they
collapse within hours if we stop and it
Trump said he's going to put a PCO for
it if Ukraine doesn't like it that's the
end I think that the moment they
announce Trump as the protected winner
Russia immediately says ceasefire
because we know what happens when Trump
comes in and we want good faith efforts
to to put an end to this and I think
Ukraine agrees knowing their funding is
about to end and it's time to find a
safe way to to retreat Donald Trump gets
on the phone I bet I bet the moment
Trump wins he's on the phone saying
we're gonna have once I'm officially in
and hands on the Bible this is done
you know I bet they'll try and get him
on the Logan act or something before
he's he's brought in office they'll try
and stop it
but I think the moment Trump is in
office he gets on the phone and says
there's no more war we're negotiating
tonight I'm flying out he flies out it's
over like you said he cuts the US cuts
off fun in Ukraine there's no war
anymore yeah so that or it continues to
ask late as you said I mean the Russians
they're 27 million people serious to
protecting their civilization that's how
many they roughly lost in World War II
and they see this as a similar threat so
they've lost what is 100 000 men so far
who cares I mean that's sad that's
terrible but they're willing to go a lot
further to protect their country their
civilization and their their land than a
hundred thousand men and they have the
population and resources to commit to
that so in in we've heard
uh what we've heard from the press the
corporate press United States is that
Leonard Putin's evil and he's like
Hitler he wants to steal land that seems
a bit one-dimensional even if that is
the case and you genuinely believe Putin
is just evil and says now's my chance to
steal Land There is a goal to the land
they are taking a strategic value to
what they're doing we don't hear it that
often in the general mentioning from the
Press much like with the war in Iraq
they hate us for our freedoms which was
completely meaningless to people who
paid attention but sure worked on those
who didn't I'm curious uh from your
point of view why did Russia invade and
what is their goal and and what are they
ultimately hoping to achieve now
to put it as quickly as possible Ukraine
is not a sovereign country it it's just
not a real country anymore it wasn't
since the U.S came in and toppled their
government in 2014. you have a sovereign
government topple your your country do
away with any form of you know elected
representation say this guy's leading
your country now if you don't like it
you know they're gonna sick these
azovite or right sector thugs on you in
the Dom bass they killed 15 000
individuals in the fighting many of whom
were civilians in the dombas from 2014
when the coup took place in 2022 the
Communist Party of the Russian
Federation is the second largest party
in Russia they were begging Putin to go
in and save these people in the dombas
for the past eight years they were
saying you're insane why are you doing
anything why are you withholding energy
to Ukraine why are you doing something
so they're very critical the other fact
here is that in 1991 Secretary of State
James Baker said NATO is not going to
extend one inch East Pass of Germany
they violated that promise I think like
16 or 18 times now they got all the way
to Ukraine that was the red line boom I
mean that that's that and uh the the
violence didn't stop the escalation
continued up until the week in which
this war started but again I don't think
this war started on February 24 2022 I
think it started back in 2014 when a
foreign government came in seized power
and started to commit violence against
any distance in the state of Ukraine
but is that do you think that the goal
of Russia is to oust the Ukrainian
government and to establish like a
legitimate government or is it actually
to control the land into Crimea that's
what it I mean strikes me that that's
what they're looking to get I think
multiple things can be true at once you
can also acknowledge that the land that
Russia sees it's resource Rich that's
12.4 mil or 12.4 trillion dollars in
resources in that 87 000 square
kilometers so multiple things can be
true at once but yeah I think the end
goal here is to have a government in
Kiev that is not backing Nazi thugs that
are killing people in the Dom bass and I
think Yanukovych was a guy who was cooed
he wasn't explicitly pro-russian uh but
he was also looking at EU contracts
doing deals with the EU and integration
with the EU I think Russia just wants
someone that's going to be fair in there
but if it comes to force and forcibly
putting someone in I think we can all
assume it's going to be someone who is
going to be pro-russian do they ever
talk publicly about their War goal the
Russian Federer of course what is their
stated goal uh state of goal is
denotification of Ukraine uh do away
with all these you know these Nazi
battalions Nazi political parties from
2014 to 2018 there was a good deal of
Nazis within the Ukrainian government
2018 onward it wasn't the case but the
chair of the forkov Narada in Ukraine
from 2014 to 2018. uh he was a self I
mean self-described Nazi this guy said
well I don't know if I should say that
here I'm not going to say it but you can
look it up online for yourself
uh these are people who really profess
these views you see the videos that
Laura Loomer posted in in Orlando this
week of these guys with swastika chains
and they're saying you know we support
Joe Biden because he's sending Rockets
to the ukrainians these are the guys
that are fighting over here these are
guys in government and they're called
Narada and they're trying to strip the
Russians of their ability to speak
Russian in Russia all that stuff right
so denotsification demilitarization is
the other goal stated goal of the
Russians that's just simply dealing with
NATO and saying you can't come over here
you can't put nukes right on our border
with they're going to be so close you
know that they said that the U.S said
that during the Cuban Missile Crisis
that the nukes in Cuba are the missiles
in Cuba that was you know a threat those
were putting uh missiles right in our
backyard well I mean like if you look at
Ukraine they're how close they are to
Russia I mean it's right on the border
and you're going to put nukes there
that's basically putting nukes in
someone's living room thanks for
watching this clip from the Tim cast IR
L podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time